YOU GUYS I HAD THE WEIRDEST DREAM LAST NIGHT...AND
YOU WERE THERE...AND YOU WERE THERE...WHAT'S
THAT?
YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT IT?
YOU SURE?
CAUSE ...OKAY.
HI GUYS THIS IS ANNIE FOR DNEWS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY RECURRING DREAMS THAT YOU
SEEM TO HAVE ALL THE TIME?
OR DREAMS THAT YOU WAKE UP FROM THINKING,
WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT ABOUT?
I DREAM ABOUT MY TEETH A LOT, AND TURNS OUT
THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST COMMON ONES.
SOME OTHERS ARE BEING NAKED IN PUBLIC...BEING
UNABLE TO SPEAK...BEING CHASED...BEING LATE
TO THE FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL.
MANY OF THESE ARE ASSOCIATED WITH ANXIETY
- THAT DREAM YOU HAVE ABOUT FAILING A TEST,
FOR EXAMPLE, THAT'S OFTEN INTERPRETED AS FEELING
UNPREPARED FOR SOMETHING, OR EXPOSED.
BUT WHY ARE CERTAIN RECURRING DREAMS SO COMMON,
AND WHAT'S THE RIGHT WAY TO INTERPRET THEM?
THAT'S A QUESTION THAT'S BEEN STUDIED FOR
AGES
IN GREECE, DREAMS WERE THOUGHT OF AS OMENS
THAT COULD PREDICT EVENTS.
IN EGYPT, THEY WERE ALSO CONSIDERED LINKS
TO THE SUPERNATURAL WORLD.
AND MANY MODERN THEORIES ORIGINATED WITH SIGMUND
FREUD, WHO SAW THEM AS WISH FULFILLMENT...THAT
HAVE A SYSTEM OF SYMBOLS THAT REPRESENT THE
SAME THINGS FOR ALMOST EVERYONE...APPLES....SNAKES....GUNS...ELEVATORS...THEY
ALL MEAN SEX.
MORE RECENTLY, A THEORY CALLED ACTIVATION
SYNTHESIS CLAIMS THAT DREAMS DON'T REALLY
MEAN ANYTHING...THEY'RE JUST ELECTRICAL IMPULSES
THAT PULL RANDOM STUFF FROM OUR MEMORIES.
DREAMS ARE TOUGH TO STUDY PARTLY BECAUSE WE
OFTEN DON'T REMEMBER THEM.
BUT ONE TEAM FROM JAPAN TRIED TO RECORD DREAM
VISUALS BY WAKING PEOPLE UP DURING DREAM PHASES
AND ASKING THEM TO DESCRIBE THEIR DREAMS.
OF THE 200 REPORTS THEY COLLECTED, THEY FOUND
THAT MOST OF THEM WERE ACTUALLY KIND OF BORING...ORDINARY
STUFF, WITH THE OCCASIONAL FORAY INTO THE
BIZARRE STUFF.
THEN THEY CATEGORIZED THE VISUALS...MAN, WOMAN,
CAR, COMPUTER, STREET.
AND WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT WHEN THEY SHOWED
THE DREAMERS IMAGES OF THOSE THINGS LATER,
THE BRAIN ACTIVITY WAS EXTREMELY SIMILAR TO
WHAT IT WAS IN THE DREAM STATE.
MEANING WE "WATCH" OUR DREAMS THE SAME WAY
WE DO REAL LIFE EVENTS.
AND BASED ON THOSE BRAIN SCANS, THE SCIENTISTS
WERE ABLE TO PREDICT WHAT PEOPLE WERE VISUALIZING
DURING THEIR DREAMS WITH 75 - 80% ACCURACY.
CRAZY RIGHT?
WE SPEND ABOUT 2 HOURS OF EVERY NIGHT DREAMING,
AND ALTHOUGH THEY'RE STILL NOT THAT WELL UNDERSTOOD
- WE DO KNOW THAT DREAMS ARE IMPORTANT FOR
MEMORY.
MOST DREAMS HAPPEN DURING REM SLEEP, WHICH
IS ASSOCIATED WITH PRODUCTION OF PROTEINS
AND THE RETENTION OF MENTAL SKILLS, AMONG
OTHER THINGS.
SO AS FOR THOSE RECURRING DREAMS...MIGHT AS
WELL EMBRACE THEM, BECAUSE THEY'RE NORMAL,
AND PROBABLY GOOD FOR YOU.
FOR MORE ON THE MYSTERIOUS SCIENCE OF SLEEP,
CHECK OUT MY REPORT ON THE ASMR PHENOMENON
THAT PEOPLE OUT THERE ARE USING TO TREAT INSOMNIA..
DO YOU HAVE RECURRING DREAMS OR NIGHTMARES?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY MEAN FOR YOU?
LET US KNOW ON TWITTER AT DNEWS OR ON FACEBOOK
AT DISCOVERY NEWS.
YOU CAN ALSO TWEET ME AT ANNIEGAUS, OR HEAD
OVER TO MY OTHER CHANNEL WTBD.
SWEET DREAMS AND THANKS FOR WATCHING.